a former U.S president Donald Trump's
due to appear in court in the coming
hours charged with plotting to overturn
his defeat in the 2020 presidential
election Trump already faces two sets of
criminal charges but this is the first
relating to his time when he was in
office he's calling for the case to be
moved out of Washington D.C which he
says is biased against him iconic
reports
the media is gathered security around
the courthouse is being ramped up and
the former president is due to be
indicted on the most serious charges yet
brought against him
one of his lawyers says the defense
rejects a trial date envisioned by the
prosecution to take president Trump to
trial in 90 days of course is absurd the
question is why do they want to do that
if you want to seek Justice then you
need to offer Mr president president
Trump an opportunity to get a hold of
all the evidence the federal judge who
was chosen at random to hear the case is
jamaican-born Tanya chitkin she was
appointed by Obama in 2014. she's
presided over dozens of prosecutions
relating to the attack on the capital on
January the 6 2021 which she has
described in one judgment as a violent
attempt to overthrow the government and
it nearly succeeded
the judge also presided over an action
brought by Donald Trump in November 2021
to prevent the White House from handing
over documents to a house select
committee she rejected the application
saying on that occasion the president is
not a king and the plaintiff is not the
president
in the conspiracy charges the
prosecution outlines the extent to which
Donald Trump attempted to persuade his
then vice president to refuse to certify
the vote does one of what the indictment
says is a series of Criminal Acts
and in relation to Trump's actions
leading up to and on January the 6th
Mike Pence issued his strongest
criticism yet and then on that day
president Trump asked me to put him over
the Constitution but I chose the
Constitution and I always will
and I I
really do believe that uh
Anyone who puts himself over the
Constitution should never be president
of the United States
and anyone who asks someone else to put
themselves over the Constitution should
never be president of the United States
again
the former president's response was
scathing in a lengthy message on his
social media Donald Trump says off Pence
he didn't fight against election fraud
which will now be easily able to prove
based on the most recent fake indictment
and information which will have to be
made available to us finally a really
big deal the VP had power that Mike
didn't understand
more than a thousand people are being
convicted on charges related to actions
stemming from this baseless claim of
election fraud some sentence to prison
terms of up to 18 years the charges are
similar to those brought against Donald
Trump
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Washington
Caster is joining us now from Washington
D.C Heidi you're going to be there as
all of this is going on over the next
few hours just talk us through uh what's
going to be happening
Rob right now it's still pretty tranquil
here outside the federal courthouse
because in a few hours time is when we
expect the former president to arrive
they'll be flying in on his private jet
from Bedminster New Jersey where his
home is and he will be escorted into the
building behind me we may or may not see
the image of him actually going into the
building because he might go through an
underground garage but once inside he
will be have he will have his
fingerprints taken once again he likely
will not have his photo or mug shot
taken and then it'll be a very
perfunctory court appearance before a
Magistrate Judge in which the charges
will be read against Trump and he'll be
asked to submit a plea and he has said
he will plead not guilty there's been
some speculation I think or some rumor
that the defense is going to try and get
the uh the case moved from Washington
D.C why is that why are they so Keen to
get that move to another location
well the jury pool here in Washington DC
according to Trump's attorneys is not a
fair one to the former president because
they're looking at the voting numbers
from the last election in which Trump
only won five percent of votes among
this jury pool so yeah it'll be
difficult to find a pool that's uh
favorable to Trump politically but what
prosecutors and what the judge in this
case and the the justice department says
is this is still an impartial Court as
it would be anywhere in the country the
judge in this case has a a good
reputation among attorneys in the area
for being one that is fair and impartial
but of course she does have that history
that we just heard about and when she's
gone toe-to-toe quite strongly against
Trump in the recent past but what is to
be expected is that Trump's attorneys
would look to move the venue or perhaps
any strategy to push the proceedings And
Delay the proceedings until after the
next presidential election which of
course is coming up in November of 2024.
trump has said no matter what the
outcome of this or his other trials that
he will face he intends to continue his
campaign which opens up an entire new
world of unknown possibilities if he
were to be convicted prior to a campaign
prior to election if he were to go on
and win what does that mean for the next
chapter of American History nobody
really knows Heidi do we have any
indication yet from the the defense how
they are going to approach this what
kind of defenses they're going to put up
against these indictments
yeah we've heard from Trump's attorneys
speaking to the media saying that the
first amendment is one defense though
likely lean on claiming that the former
president had the right to tell the
public far and wide that the election
had been stolen and stolen and that he
at the time and even now still believes
that to be the truth well we know from
the evidence and from what the
indictment lays out that Trump was
informed time and time again from
credible sources including his own
justice department that the last
election the 2020 presidential election
was indeed secure and that there was not
fraud enough to over to change the
outcome that Trump had lost and that
Trump deliberately chose to ignore those
facts in the indictment it says many
times that he knowingly spread these
falsehoods and that it was that action
which crossed the line from just
expressing his first amendment opinion
to taking a corrupt act according to
prosecutors and that he not only said
those lies but he also had corrupt
pressure on his Department of Justice
officials and on state election
officials trying to push them to take an
illegal action to throw out votes for
Joe Biden who which they all refused to
do notably but that is what the line
that the prosecutors say he crossed that
went far beyond just expressing his
first amendment Free Speech yep Heidi I
know you're going to be guiding us
through what happens over the next few
hours but for now Heidi Joe Castro in
Washington D.C thank you very much